the Joe Rogan experience me and one uh
again this is something here's things
you wish you had on tape about nineteen
ninety eight ish me Mitch Hedberg and
greg Giraldo both did sets we all free
listed sets at the Comedy Cellar and
there was an old diner on a ninth and
twenty-third called Chelsea Square diner
I don't know if it's silly anymore the
three of us was me Greg and Mitch and if
you if you ask why God spared me out of
that three I have no idea it's just
sheer luck but God spared me for some
reason I don't know why and I remember
talking the three of us were talking
about about drugs and Hedberg he told
this to a couple people and I didn't
know Mitch's well I did a couple of gigs
with him but you know he said you know a
lot of people are trying to get me to
stop I'm never gonna stop he said I'm
just just don't waste your time I'm
never gonna stop doing it I love it that
much and you know at the time I didn't
realize how dark that was and he died
you know he's been dead almost 15 years
now you talk about a real genius you
know and like he just was like I I just
I know I can never stop like that's how
much it takes it takes over to the point
where you know you know you might die I
because I don't care I want to do it
this way yeah you know so again well
remember when he almost died from
gangrene
yes he was shooting it's the same hole
he was going through he might have been
with a towel I don't know and Louis
black they did a tour together and again
that's one of the saddest stories yet
the security at the airport smelled the
gangrene oh that's how they found out
yeah and they found [ __ ] I think he'd
beat the case I think they found like
powerful nail your stuff but you're
talking about you know one of the best
maybe the best joke writer ever and he
just doesn't eat just like I just why
again when you live in this life like
stand-ups most of us dreamed of doing
this our whole lives and now you're
doing it who's gonna tell you to stop
anything I think with him to they were
inseparable they'll stand up in the
heroine together yeah like Miles Davis
said they get we're playing the trumpet
you know it's no mean again you're
talking about extreme personalities
yeah John Belushi yeah and again like
you say you have the same personality
but it just manifested itself in
different ways I was lucky when I was a
kid I knew junkies my friend Jimmy's
cousin was selling coke when I was in
high school I watched him brought away
I watched him shrivel up and and I
remembered I I was also I was very
paranoid right and I didn't I didn't
want to ruin my life I was always
worried about ruining my life yeah so
I'd see things like that all right stay
the [ __ ] away from drugs that's amazing
amazingly mature attitude at that point
because I was a direct option I said
that's gonna be part of the success yeah
for me hard salvation yeah and look
that's a smart way to think but III tell
I tell when I speak I tell these kids
because they're like how did you make it
man like how did you make it in show biz
like they Google me and they see me you
know on The Tonight Show yeah how did
you do that
like in rehab they would get like you
know they're watching my movies on
YouTube these kids are magicians with
the [ __ ] thing and I stand up and I
go how did you do this like being a
junkie and I'm like I don't know I can't
even remember but that's part of the
problem is that you're kind of rewarded
for being so wild and being wild you're
you're it's an accentuated yes are the
drugs yes and by the craziness I'm
gambling and all of it well the way I
say the way Ray Romano wrote new jokes
about having kids and a family yeah you
know a lot of comics you you comment on
your life yes that's how you get new
material so my life was not a wife and
kids my life was just craziness with
drugs and gambling and that's that's
where I sort of I mind that for material
and it's also the audience loved it they
loved the fact that you're out there
living that life like right Kowski or
Hunter Thompson yeah anyone who's out
there live in that life there's like
it's romantic yes yes you you're not
living like the average schlub no but
Ray Liotta says it in Goodfellas like
you know we we were rock stars yeah you
know all these guys want to wake up and
go to a nine-to-five job we don't know
that life you know and and I said dude I
saw the other side when I was at this
halfway house with all these crazy
[ __ ] I had to get a job as part
of the program so I
gasps and I I worked the back of a
garbage truck for a while throwing
garbage and I pumped gas as a kid and
you know you know the money we make for
being on stage I've gone from that money
I'm a I pump gas 40 hours one week I got
a check for $280 you know so that's what
that's life yeah that's real life that's
real life yeah okay start by this kid in
the halfway house I had five three
roommates one was a carjacker the other
one was an arsonist okay
this other kid was it was a jerk this
kid was my bunkmate he lived on the top
bunk I was on the bottom he's like 22
year old he had some 40 had a form of
Tourette's every 11 seconds my hand to
God he made this sound high to sleep he
watched porn on his on his phone so he
loved the specific kind of porn and he
would keep showing it to me's jerking
off on the top bunk and I got to go pump
gas the next day I'm like my life is
[ __ ] over and he loved watching these
really fat black chicks get [ __ ] by
small white guys okay so this is what
you hear all night you hear this [ __ ] me
with that honky dick hi little white
[ __ ] is even in like he gels like kills
he's in the old days people just lit him
on fire right and throw him in a
dumpster right but now it's a disease
right so he's got a disease so but he
the kid I go you're on a [ __ ]
Internet you can watch the hottest
chicks on the planet he with jerk-off
these days I go those chicks look like
the 86 Celtics that looks like Bill
Walton but then it's like this enormous
like Oprah lookin chick with a little
like Richard Simmons looking guy and he
goes hey did you ask him wise into that
sort of but no explanation made any
sense I was in jail with I was in
protective custody so if you're a
protective custody I tell you you it
means you're a murderer a snitch or some
sort of celebrity so you're up there
with hardcore
[ __ ] so this this black it was next
to me in the cell great kid I love them
I love them but when me and him were
both adding cell together for rec time I
noticed the guards were real protective
of me like now they would make him go in
the shower and lock the shower while I
walk past them he had some sort of
ghetto Tourette's or something like
because every okay he'd ask you a
question about your life and then he
would interrupt you by going word up
like everything so I'm gonna ask you a
question just start to answer okay
what's your name Joe burn up where you
from
word up born in Jersey word up he'd get
every 11 seconds he went word up were up
I love the guy I was okay because I'm
locked in my cell 23 hours a day one of
the guards told me he the guy chopped up
three women oh shut up yeah whoo so
that's the you're rubbing elbows with
these guys Jesus each I I think he
chopped up three girls the most affable
I like the kid I still basketball what
I'm like the pace day was playing and
yeah cuz you're in solitary confinement
was he able to have conversations he was
mentally ill obviously but but he kept
he kept like I heard on a phone the
other thing about jail man they have
tablets now they have the technology so
I for one hour a day I was out of my
cell and they you you could play
basketball or whatever but you're in
these cages so they give these young
kids who are in jail for a long time
tablets they could call anybody on the
outside so they call their girlfriends
which is always a bad thing like it
starts out nice but you hear the bill
like how you do a baby with who's that
who's that in the background who the
[ __ ] is that and they start screaming at
him and they get violent and I go don't
call your girlfriend mm-hmm and when
this kid would talk to anybody's life he
kept saying wear it up every five
[Applause]